ladies and gentlemen we have made it to
Transformers Dark of the Moon the third
installment in this franchise that is
about to have a fifth installment I've
already reviewed age of extinction so
this is going to be the last review in
this series leading up to the last night
this film had a lot to live up to
because revenge of the Fallen was awful
and this is coming from somebody who can
watch or Michael Bay movie and just have
fun who isn't going to sit in the
theater angry just because he's watching
a Michael Bay movie he's made good
movies before and as I said in my
previous reviews he assembles really
well-made productions and is excellent
at incorporating CGI and sound design
and sound effects and all these things
to make a really entertaining visual
experience but with transformers it's
the even-numbered entries that I really
do not like two and four so maybe five
could actually be okay let's talk about
three this movie opens up connecting the
moon landing and president JFK with the
Transformers lore apparently Sentinel
Prime crashed on the moon and was
trapped there for quite some time we get
a CGI JFK and in present day the
Autobots are getting a lot of heat from
the government because the government
doesn't like Autobots because you know
big robots and explosions and shit and
they free Sentinel Prime eventually
causing some serious havoc and Sam has a
new girlfriend because Megan Fox was
like yeah no thanks so now we have rosie
huntington-whiteley
because she's a model and she can look
like this when things are exploding
behind her Dark of the Moon is weird
because you can tell that they and his
writing team are trying to make a better
film than the last one
they actually took some of the criticism
they removed mudflap and skids a lot of
the really terrible humor has been
removed from this movie as well that
being said it's replaced with a first
act and a second act
that's rather dull we have Sam Witwicky
trying to find a job John Malkovich is
his extremely tan employer Ken Jong is
this conspiracy theorist who works there
who kids killed really quickly I mean
there's all of this stuff in the first
half of this movie that just is so dull
and it's sad because you can tell that
Bay and his writing team are trying to
make a better film a film with a more
cohere
narrative because that was one of the
biggest issues with her revenge of the
fallen not just the stupid jokes and the
plot that was so jumbled and didn't make
any sense the narrative of that film was
just a mess this time around they have
streamlined it somewhat better they try
to focus on the moon-landing stuff and
how that somehow relates to transformers
in their past and how it's going to all
come back to them now but this film just
gets so bogged down in Sam Witwicky
trying to find a job because his new
girlfriend is very rich and she works
for Patrick Dempsey who is also very
rich and likes to give her cars and
really expensive meals this is all stuff
that nobody asked for nobody wants this
in a Transformers movie we all just want
to see the Transformers I'm not against
Shia LaBeouf at all I think I've made
that pretty clear in my reviews of the
Transformers movies I actually think
he's pretty good in these movies
especially this one he gives a much
better performance in this film than he
did in the last one because in the last
one it seemed like just about everybody
involved with that production was just
scurrying away like rats everyone trying
to get away as fast as possible and
whoever was left behind took the blame
for that thing he's much better here and
I'm fine with him incorporated in these
movies I think what they really could
have done to improve this film was just
forget about the whole new girlfriend
thing Megan Fox didn't want to be in it
fine just let him be single I think it
would have made this film considerably
better we wouldn't have had to worry
about a girl constantly screaming every
time something happened or Shia LaBeouf
constantly screaming Carla the same time
Shia LaBeouf does scream along these
movies but I mean it's not like it's his
fault the dialogue says oh I mean it's
written in the script you've got to do
it and that's my biggest issue with dark
of the Moon it's that first half him
trying to find a job
his girlfriend problems patrick dempsey
creating a love triangle can he make
enough money to support his girlfriend
despite the fact that the first half of
this movie is rather dull the last half
is basically non-stop action with the
entire city of Chicago being taken over
by the Decepticons and that's where the
film finally picks up and we actually
have a lot of transformers awesomeness
and
all I care about seeing I don't go to
these movies expecting anything else
and the fact that there's so much
baggage constantly given to these films
it's annoying because I just want to see
Optimus Prime slicing through people
punching people and Megatron looking
like a Mad Max motherfucker and it looks
fucking badass that design is clearly
very inspired by the road warrior and I
love it Leonard Nimoy a Sentinel Prime
is clearly a big wink to the fans
because he voiced Galvatron in the
original animated film and here when he
goes bad and switches sides to the
Decepticons it's like yeah that was
incredibly obvious so I knew that from
the very beginning like why are we all
surprised by this note and this isn't
surprising at all and it's funny because
watching this finale really reminds me
of the Avengers which came out a year
after this so part of me wonders if
Whedon saw this and was in any way
inspired to kind of weave that into his
film because we have the alien ships
coming out of the sky an entire city
being destroyed everyone's running
everywhere it really looks like there's
even a beam in the sky this is one of
the first compete in the sky movies and
now like every movie as a beam in the
sky because who doesn't love a good beam
in the sky and while I must admit this
entire finale is actually quite a bit of
fun and really technically well
assembled there are so many stupid
moments sprinkled throughout there's
more drama with Patrick Dempsey and his
crusade to help the Decepticons and it's
just such bullshit I could not care less
about it I just want that characters why
it coulda just removed all that from the
movie seriously just removed Patrick
Dempsey and the girlfriend just movie
would have been ten times better no
doubt but that being said as I said
there's a lot of really stupid moments
throughout this entire finale like the
fact that Sam is basically a superhero
he survives so much when he shoots his
grappling hook into one of the
Decepticons eyes he swings around with
that thing for like a good three minutes
how he survived without many broken
bones is beyond me there were other
times in this movie where he does things
and I'm like what where did that even
come from like randomly during the
finale he just starts doing parkour or
Shia LaBeouf stunt-double does and I'm
just thinking while watching this like
were you in high school a few years ago
and you were looking for a job earlier
you got one with John Malkovich and now
you're doing parkour through Chicago
this movie also has
a too many wings of the camera like
Leonard Nimoy voicing Sentinel Prime
saying the system failed to understand
that the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of the future
logic clearly dictates that the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
was that like design for people in the
theater to go I heard that before
oh wow I've heard that yes
[Applause]
ah - in summation the first half of this
movie has so much unnecessary exposition
constantly scenes with everybody just
going here's a bunch of photos of this
photos of this here's a file of this
this is what you need to know I'm
walking really fast in a corridor and
what I'm saying means something and I'm
walking fast so you better listen and
I'm important and then a bunch of
unnecessary girlfriend stuff and Patrick
Dempsey similar to the first film and
the second one there is a good 30
minutes hunk of this movie that could be
removed and if they're too streamlined
it down and it would have been a really
entertaining action movie but that first
half is just so bland the second half
gracefully does improve and it becomes a
really exciting action movie in Chicago
even though there's still a lot of
superhero II stuff that makes no sense
it's a Transformers movie what really
more can I expect I'm gonna give
Transformers Dark of the Moon a c+
definitely an improvement over the last
one but still not as good as the first
one it has a lot of really exciting
action sequences but still it's just
another really weighed down Transformers
movie by a bunch of stuff that doesn't
have to be in the movie but I certainly
don't hate this one it's far more
watchable than the last one that's for
sure guys look forward to my review of
transformers the last night as always if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck menage
[Music]
you